hello you're watching games thought
daily where we cover six news stories in
30 minutes or less and I forgot to come
up with a joke today I'm Callie and I
Drive by Michael hi um it's Friday it's
Friday thanks for that Friday the 13th
to be exact it is oh my god it is spoopy
I didn't even for me dude I don't even
realize it was Friday the 13th but that
could have fed into the joke that I'm
supposed to say every morning so dang
damn that's enough it's only a ball dude
our first week so we got time to improve
hopefully you'll let us all y'all out
there will let us improve over time
we're not perfect yet but we will get
there oh yes we will get there and you
know not everybody's perfect and that's
why fortnight how to do this latest
thing that's our first story oh yes
yes for tinnitus is is good but it's far
from perfect and here's a one example
for tonight freebies are now available
to all players after recent server
issues so it's kind of like a make good
so for tonight's latest patch which was
update 3.5 was followed by a bunch of
server issues and it rendered the game
unplayable for a lot of people on all
platforms so epic said on its website
it's been no secret that over the past
24 hours we've been experiencing issues
with our services that have prevented
many of you from playing battle royale
and save the world people still play
save the world I don't know about that
just kidding we're sorry we know how
frustrating this has been we messed up
here you know what I respect I respect
the heck out of that yeah that's good so
the server yeah server issues have been
ironed out for the most part but Epic
Games is offering some freebies
including in Battle Royale the battle in
the battle royale mode you will get a
get free back bullying and pack of
battle stars used to rank up your battle
pass in save the world you'll get a
troll stache llama which is a legendary
loot box if you aren't familiar and an
unspecified amount of seasonal gold I'm
gonna admit I don't know what that means
you don't gold it sounds tasty seasonal
gold um you have it yeah the back bling
in the troll troll stash llama
we claim now for a limited time in their
respective modes in game stores yeah so
the Battlestars and gold on the other
hand will be distributed during a
downtime sometime next week
okay so you gotta wait a little while to
get you get you a seasonal gold and your
battle stars but go ahead and claim your
your back bling yeah and you know they I
I respect people or companies that can
admit when they messed up and that's
nice it sucks when you can't play a game
that you really like sure that's the
most that's most obvious thing I've ever
said man I had this this didn't happen
while I was trying to review the damn
thing yeah but tip for tonight's
generally had been very very good on the
technical side of things so this is uh
just one slip-up it's all good ain't no
thing but yeah so they're gonna give you
awesome freebies so if you're super
hands for tonight
get your [ __ ] there you have it get your
[ __ ] and it's speaking of speaking of
getting your [ __ ] yeah guess I get some
dope stuff this weekend cuz we have some
free stuff available we don't get myself
we get trouble we had free bagels that's
about the limit of what we have but
there are a bunch of free weekends going
on for ps4 Xbox one and PC games so no
matter where you play except for switch
you can get some stuff for free so we
got from now until April 15th we're
gonna go buy game and tell you the
platform's ok yeah just so you know
because I think a lot of people will be
more interested in the game so the first
one and actually you know before I
started gonna pull up a gameplay of this
game because okay I love this game the
first one is Skyrim special edition
which is available for free on Steam and
Xbox one and for Xbox you need to have
an Xbox Live Gold account it's
discounted by 50% which amounts to $20
in the US and the special edition of
course includes enhanced graphics and
all of the expansions for Skyrim
it's got to get rid of this ad here do
your taxes do time is up do your taxes
right now okay so in addition to being
able to try out Skyrim special edition
fo free Ghost Recon wildlands is also
having a free weekend on ps4 Xbox one
and PC this coincides actually with the
recently released Sam Fisher mission so
for all your Splinter Cell fans out
there if you haven't gotten so it goes
to Recon wildlands you could jump in and
get a little taste of Michael Ironside
once again
well which if completed by May 16th will
get you some special bonuses including
Sam Fisher's goggles and wildlands is
also on sale if you want to just buy it
after you try it you could buy it for 67
percent off 67 two-thirds of the price
is slashed off I do some math out there
yeah that was great
quick man great fraction conversion and
it's on all three platforms so if you're
in the u.s. that's $20 sorry we're not
we're good at math over here but not so
good that we can just do on-the-fly
conversions to different currencies yeah
also Xbox Live Gold required for all
these games if you're doing it on Xbox
one just okay so you know next is
injustice 2 which is free on ps4 and
Xbox one this weekend it's discounted by
40% as well that's pretty yeah pretty
big price slash dope fighting game all
your DC superheroes superheroes
that's alluding to that's somewhere
shattering yeah
stay tuned yeah halo 5 guardians is also
free on Xbox one for up until April 15
again Xbox Live Gold is required and
it's discounted by 20% so it's 16 bucks
if you're counting the US dollars he was
already pretty discounted since it came
out and three years almost three years
old at this point I don't think I own it
actually maybe I should hmm I played it
like I borrowed a copy 16 dollars in
that month the multiplayer is fun yeah
oh yeah multiplayer spawn I'm kind of
over halo though is not over halo
yeah jump into halo 5 Guardians hell
yeah and then lastly we have ballistic
overkill which is an online class based
shooter that quote blends classic arena
shooter action with modern FPS gunplay
and that is discounted by 50% which is a
really affordable six dollars in the
u.s.
and that's less than how much I pay for
lunch every day oh yeah that is luck
that is less or more than know math is
hard I pay like twelve to fourteen
dollars for lunch every day here and say
yeah we got some ballers over here man I
just want to do that I spend sometimes
sometimes I spend $0 on lunch and I just
start myself or I just go to the vending
machine get a Snickers I've done that
before it's all that's you know you know
you're in a good place when you get that
vending machine lunch um all right you
know who's in a good place
sony Sony is in a very good place Kratos
and so it's great as well
I haven't finished a God of War so I
don't know if he's in a good place but I
hope you is obeyed Reese's too but
overall Sony Santa Monica in a good
place and because of that Phil Spencer
Xbox boss Phil Spencer congratulated
Sony on positive God of War reception
that's very nice of him um so reviews
are live for God of War right now
they're very very positive very Peter
Brown reviewed it for us he really liked
it said it was a fantastic game um you
can read his review we also have review
roundup so you're gonna see kind of like
what the temperature is and the
temperature is the game's great it's
very hot super hot yeah so Phil Spencer
who is a tends to be an affable guy he's
really cool I love to describe him but
he is very cool yeah yeah hello I love I
love me some Phil Spencer but yes he's
uh he congratulated Sony and Sony Santa
Monica on such such a great game release
or not even know no not even a release
just the review scores in general yeah
so he said this on Twitter yeah on
Twitter he said congrats Sony Santa
Monica and Shuhei Yoshida on the review
scores and the upcoming launch of God of
War looks like a special launch for the
franchise great job
and then Shuhei responded with a thank
you Shuhei or Shiva is also really
freaking cool and nice yeah dope dude
and then finally Major Nelson xbox of
Xbox aka Matt pageant hahaha Matt
Paget's icon in all of our like chat
that were holding him xbox
Major Nelson of Xbox Fame also chimed in
with some congratulations so that's
nice I like it when everyone gets along
and everyone's nice which um you know
people weren't people got really mad
about some of those reviews on Twitter
and I think that we could all just get
along because we all thought the game
was that's a lot to ask Callie jeez man
come on yeah
this is you know Phil Phil's been been
like this for a while he's not like all
this is how I how I get good like with
was how I build some rep well it is how
you built some rep but like it's it's
genuine it comes from a genuine place I
know we talked to Phil Spencer a lot too
during last year's e3 I said what's up
to him and it's a lot like cross cross
play and he's like yeah man I'm dead I'm
down with it like of course because like
Xbox is kind of like trailing behind
more or less but when he was talking
about him he's like yeah man why can't
we all just get along and he's also on
the night show with Giant Bomb and he's
just like kicking it talking about games
even hikes it doesn't matter like he's
not it's very not trimmed for a little
he's not like super corporate when he
gets on right and talks so this is just
another example of like yeah Xbox and
Sony are competitors but they the people
who work there are human beings and the
same goes for the people who review
those games looking at you people on
Twitter your scenes you say mean things
to me yours yeah and so just it's just
nice I like the good spirit of it and
then you know just to give a shout out
to Peter Brown we have a quote here from
our very own God of War Review where
Peter said God of War is no longer an
old-fashioned action series with this
reboot it confidently walks a new path
that will hopefully lead to more
exciting adventures to come yeah glowing
praise look how beautiful this game is -
there are so many things that that
people have are praising about God of
War like the beautiful environments and
how it actually like stretches the
limitations of the PlayStation 4 like
this is something like Naughty Dog is
kind of like been Naughty Dog and
gorillas have been like the two
developers who've really stretched the
power of the ps4 and now Sony Santa
Monica of course the first party company
so you would kind of expect that but to
see it in action that's what's up yeah
yeah very excited to play this game and
be very very excited I know I'm
listening to all like this whole week my
podcast feeds open up updated with all
all the podcasts at let's do an everyone
saw my god war and it's nothing but at
first I was kind of like good hey cuz I
played it before lunch you know yeah I'm
sorry did you get to play what God of
War did you get to preview God of War I
didn't I didn't had no idea I did that's
right that's me he's mentioned it on the
last two episodes of this show and like
once an hour on the hour
yeah at work yeah we were in a meeting
yesterday I'm like hey guys thanks for
inviting me because I actually I did
play it I don't know why I was in that
meeting because I know it's interesting
I just like Moore's gods
so anyway who's your favorite Norse God
the hella okay that's what's up
she's badass color yeah so anyway you
know what - that was just the first one
I could think of I don't know what's
yours I don't know hey Thor that's the
only Loki Loki oh you know what let's uh
let's just just do a hard right talking
about keys talk about key is this one
okay okay good job um next story game
collector finds drugs in NES cartridges
this comes from kotaku this person his
name is Julian Turner I don't know why I
had to say like Julian Julian Turner a
game collector in Georgia found drugs in
two old NES carts I asked Peter Brown
about this because he's a big-time game
collector and he was like oh yeah that's
a thing oh really and I was like what
so did he say whether or not he's this
has happened to him before he said when
he worked I forget where he he's
definitely like that's a thing where
like you find like weed in old
cartridges because like you could open
it up and put stuff inside hi baby
so anyway Julian Turner bought roller
games and golf from a flea market and
the carts felt heavier than he expected
and the roller games cart was a pal
version a PIL version I don't know do
people say pal or PAL it's as well
yeah so Oh what are the kids say wait
that that OpenCart
found bags bags of undisclosed drugs yes
so you can see show you God we got a
here's a here I'm opening the carts
[Music]
slang embrace out well break this link
bricks out of NES cards man yeah I don't
even do that back in my uh snitch all
myself
yeah anyway the Turner called the cops
they confirmed that the drugs had been
in the carts a long time so whoever
bought them did not get them those are
some old drugs
Turner looked around on the internet and
found out that another copy of golf had
been stuffed with five thousand dollars
in bills and that was discovered in 2012
it's apparently yeah that's a come-up
right there
video games are the key to the drug
trade okay yeah look I got I got breaks
on me almost laying this no he called
the cops oh well it's just lying to the
cops
yeah I just if I did interesting that I
had never heard about this but
apparently it's a super widespread an
obvious thing they're the perfect size
and super innocent looking I know I
should have done this man oh oh my god
is he gonna Wow are we allowed to show
this well it's on YouTube so YouTube
that's on the YouTube there's a lot of
shady things listen listen you can't do
these drugs they're super old apparently
do they expire don't they
or they lay just like it like really
hardened cake kicked up what I don't I
don't really know what's this video is
something else so anyway we can conclude
that um but yeah that's it I I just
didn't know that was the thing drug
trade daily okay well that's what we're
here for it's an interesting story
that's super interesting I might call it
fun but it's fun for us it's fun for us
cuz we get to make lots of jokes but
also it's it's dangerous it's definitely
illegal
yeah so if you're gonna if you're gonna
buy NES cards or any retro parts out
there in flea markets like some of us do
make sure you
you shake them around hold on make sure
they weight properly and if they don't
buy them especially if they don't and
you buy oh yep
trust me yep we got you okay okay let's
do it let's do like a real real sharp
Busker skirt yeah we're we're just like
all over the road today this is also
kind of related to Norse mythology a
little bit I'm just going back to that
hell-blade took home a bunch of Baptists
this comes from PC gamer he'll blades
sending a sacrifice came out last year
as one of my favorite games of last year
it just came out on xbox and we updated
their review it plays really well on
xbox I don't worry about that um but it
took home five Baptist so you want to
read out the British Academy was it the
British Academy of video games the
British Academy games Awards yes okay I
know where the F comes in there yeah
but here so they won five Awards so
let's run through the five awards that
they did get so they got artistic
achievement audio achievement best
performer for Molina organs who plays
Sinhala mhm breasts great best best
British game and game beyond
entertainment award so anyway the cool
thing about Molina Jurgen z-- is she was
like a video editor at Ninja Theory yeah
Ninja Theory um the developer and they
had her kind of just stand-in to do the
capture just a test stuff I guess and
she was so good they were like no you're
yours anyway let's just do that was
really really cool yeah that's that's
dope you know start from the bottom well
that's not really sorry from the bottom
but but but now we're here and she won
at the Game Awards the Jeff Kelly Game
Awards as well luckily came yeah yeah so
hell-blade is a hell of a game it's
super important it it so respectfully
handles mental illness and tells that
story really beautifully I would highly
recommend it worth noting it didn't
when best game at the BAFTAs that went
to but remains of Edith Finch which is
also a phenomenal game mm-hmm these
games are getting us in our feelings
yeah I love it when a game hits me right
in my feelings mhm
me too awesome definitely I like I like
a good cry I'm grown-ass man but I do
like to cry oh yeah you just sometimes
you got to get the tears out you just
got it's a cathartic yeah you got to
release those toxins by toxins I mean
bad feelings mm-hmm yeah anyway and then
you know what on that note we got a fun
double feature for you yeah speaking of
getting me my feelings oh yeah you want
to feel stuff there's no better place
than anime anime oh we we always try and
fit in anime whenever we can and this is
it that's the secret purpose of this
show yeah and we're not gonna let anyone
else tell this otherwise and something
that's got me and my feelings right now
is my hero academia hmm so we've got two
pieces of my hair academia news the
first is that my hero academia will be
in an infinity or collaboration and
that's the first because this is the one
I pulled up first so this is kind of a
smaller story but the official Avengers
Japan account which is a VG underscore
JP on Twitter and it's verified so I'm
assuming it's official Avengers account
it announced the collaboration via a
tweet and posted a website with all
sorts of videos and superhero
comparisons and showing like a zoo coup
as often America yeah we can pull that
up we can oh I'm not sure if I perfectly
aligned with the with the my hero
academia and Avengers comparisons but we
can now run through them yeah so this is
a Japanese language website but it's
Avengers infinity war in my hair
academia we got you know they recreated
the Avengers infinity war trailer with
the my hero academia characters is how
you got Japan to see Avengers exactly
and it just has like we got a trailer
we'll play the trailer in a second so
easy coup is Captain America Captain
America mm-hmm and bucko go is a Iron
Man yep well chuckle is Black Widow I
don't know if I agree with that and eda
is
dr. strange yes
Todoroki is Thor no I don't think that's
true if anything Thor's the god of
lightning right yeah so you shoot it
should be dinky
yeah yeah uh and then we got all might
as the Hulk who might Oh what am i - and
Haruka Haruka Haruka okay how dukkha is
uh she's some uh Yogi's a daughter yeah
but she's not but let's see I don't know
if I'd say all my tis the Hulk I doesn't
have he does have have Hulk qualities
but all my looks just like Captain
America oh yeah all my TASM is more but
anyway so I really like this because
it's like easy to watching them like
video but he was watching The Avengers
trailer and they're like I want to be a
hero like I wanna be the best hero like
in the background this is this is some
some promotion for Japan so this is yeah
crossover is like this like crossover
promotions are super common in Japan it
makes a lot of sense and then of course
Touhou animation posted this trailer and
they're the production company that
produces my hair academia so it seems
pretty official at least the like this
part it's not like an April Fool's like
a really late April Fool's joke or
anything yeah yeah so there's that
superheroes there's there's that and
then we got another my hair academia
story for you this one is about
videogames
so my car academia once justice got an
announcement trailer the new the
upcoming my hair academia fighting game
and it's got some gameplay to show off
gameplay so let's let's walk it's a
fighting game based on the anime the
trailer shows a couple things so you
want to walk me through some of these
things yeah so we get to see it plays
reminiscent to what i think is like
naruto ultimate ninja storm so it's a 3d
fighter that isn't like it's not like
tekken 3d fighter it's like like you
know in an arena fighter i guess you
could say so yeah we have to see
everyone using off they're using their
quirks
so you see you using his oh his one for
all
his version of one for all of his little
his little middle finger like make sure
he doesn't break his arm when he uses
one fur on then we uh we see we saw him
fighting back ago and everyone's got
their quirks you see uh you know with
his super fast legs and all OH
see you as uh she's one of my favorites
I love her oh I almost so but also
properties very important yes and it
shows up the sidekick system which is
just bringing in two characters to
assist you this is very reminiscent of
like the ultimate ultimate ninja storm
games or like some of the one-piece
fighting games are like this as well and
has if you've noticed it has kind of
like a manga style so they have like the
the sound effects and all that although
all the original voice actors of course
are there naturally and then a it showed
off stage destruction as well oh yeah
that's gonna be lets me pretty dope so
I'll see you but I hope they they take
this to a very to the extent as strong
as possible because you do some really
interesting things I think the I had a
lot of fun with naruto ultimate ninja
storm but it was a little little flats
overall but here with all the all the
different courts i think you could do
some interesting things with stage
instruction and we could see you at the
play is all my own yeah so yeah we
didn't there's other characters we got
stained shigaraki tamara and all my yeah
so we got the pro heroes and we got the
villains as well yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see what how once justice
turns out I am I want to play it now
that I'm a super into my hero academia
mmm-hmm so it's coming out this year and
it's coming out to a bunch of different
platforms which I was kind of surprised
its XBOX PC ps4 and in ten dos which if
I'm not mistaken though I've read this
on the mic Iraq gave me a wiki page so
maybe it's not entirely true I think ps4
and Nintendo switch is a worldwide
release then PC and Xbox might be Europe
only that I mean I should probably
verify that before I wouldn't be shocked
because Xbox is just not really a big
thing in Japan
so I wouldn't be terribly surprised if
Xbox and PC had slightly different I'll
get back to you all on that but yeah but
otherwise worldwide launch I'll probably
get it on switch that's I don't know
kind of that's pretty cool
you could play it while you're watching
my hero academia yeah I want hope it's
at least deep in some sense there's some
there's some heroes that I don't know
how their quirks are gonna work
like like EDA like he's super fast he
runs super fast so I don't know if how
they're gonna translate that maybe you
can fight obviously but yeah I don't
know if he's these courts will translate
extremely well but I think almost the
other like I was it um Izawa the
Eraserhead
yeah I don't know how his is gonna
translate I know he can disable other
people's quirks or other heroes courts
that would be pretty ope
yeah we'll see hopefully we get to try
it out soon enough
yes so you can put the story of the day
is that there's new trailer for my hair
academia once justice the 3d fighting
game that's coming up this year and
they're doing some cute cross promotion
in Japan between the avengers affinity
war and my hero academia yes that is
your anime story of the day if you want
to watch my hair academia it's airing on
crunchyroll Hulu and Funimation and then
I believe it's probably on anime lab if
you're in Australia New Zealand because
Australia New Zealand use anime lab
pretty much exclusively and yeah and the
first season or the first season the
third season started last weekend so the
second episode will be coming out this
weekend and the dubbed version if you're
into the dub
that's not funny mission they had to
delay the first episode dub but the
second should be on track so from now on
if you're into the dub it'll be on track
on Funimation really quick shout out to
one of my favorite anime streaming
resource websites which is because dot
mo a because mo e that's it's a search
engine where you can just search any any
anime see where it is legally streaming
because you want to support the anime
industry because anime creators work
really long hours and like they put
their heart soul
at work and they make no money so it's
really important to support them legally
and get those official translations and
substance ups so I really like that site
because it shows you can pick your
region you can pick like US UK Australia
and it'll show you where to find the
shows you want to watch alright so
support your favourite artists out there
that's no they don't do this for free so
support support people who make things
that they like yeah and that mean a lot
to you yeah so that's my my bump for
today yeah speaking of anime that are
getting episodes every weekend episode 2
of persona 5 the animation is gonna be
out tomorrow morning
oh yeah I'm probably gonna I'm probably
the ketchup on my hair academia we have
like I'm in the middle of season 2 but
I'm probably gonna catch up because
that's what I want to do tonight and I'm
gonna be able to catch up for season 3
so yay got an amazin the come-up anime
was not a mistake yeah if you say it oh
if you say say that say that to my face
yeah higher up I'll use my quirk on
y'all because I was like what's my quirk
what would be your court that I just I
you know what I I think I'm less of a my
hair I get even more of a sailor scout
okay I'm I'm probably on if I'm being
honest with myself probably the guardian
of love and justice which is Sailor Moon
even there's kind of a crybaby a Ric I
really care about love and justice okay
but I have a Sailor Jupiter cosplay
that's what's up but I'll probably wear
a fanime anyway that's your anime news
of the day and your other news of the
day that we did talk about we talked
about some other things um so yeah this
it's Friday which means we are not gonna
be back until Monday yeah this is so we
close out we're closing out our first
week of GameSpot Bailey it feels good
yeah we hope you really really we hope
you guys really enjoyed the show this
week we're obviously gonna keep
workshopping it so please let us know in
the comments what you think don't be
mean a couple other things potato mode
the amazing new show from GameSpot where
Joey takes a partner and they completely
break games they did crisis this week
can it run crisis can it what can it run
Christ Daniel one crisis that's up
now you could watch that last week in
Far Cry 5 they've done GTA 5 it's a
hilarious show definitely check it out
that's every Friday on GameSpot jean-luc
psyche did history of God of War he
produces those and he does an incredible
job so he was the historian again so
common is genius yeah so in anticipation
of the release of the new god of war
which is next week we do have the
history up so you can catch up on all
your kratos all your lure your mythology
before you jump into the new game and
lastly we'll be streaming Monster Hunter
if you're watching live that's right
after this show if you're not watching
live you can check that out on YouTube
anyway I wrote Monster Hunter hunty
because I thought it was funny and it
made me laugh but you can get Megaman
gear for your palico right now for a
limited time so there's your monitor
Monster Hunter shoutout and that's all
the time we have thank you Matt Padgett
Tony Wilson Chris Pereira Erik Tay Emily
consi thank you thank you thank you for
being with us it means a lot so come
back every day next week and for the
rest of our lives to support us and get
some news with that piece bye bye have a
good weekend